[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
مخرج الفيلم للمانويل ميراندا العنوا ان
هو فيلم موسيقي من الدرجه الاولى بس هل هو
فعلا فيلم موسيقي ولا بايوكرفي ولا دراما
ولا فيلم مسرحي الحقيقه كل الاوصاف دي
بتنطبق على فيلم تيك تيك
في حلقه جديده من بودكا الافلام والنهارده
هاخدك في رحله مستحيل تنساها رحله فقدان
الامل بعد سنين عناء وفي النهايه العالم
كله بيفتكرك رحله تيك تيك بوم في البدايه
خليني اقول لك ان فيلم تيك تيك بوم ماخوذ
عن قصه حقيقيه عن المؤلف الموسيقي جوناسين
وكان يا مكان وكنا في سنه
1992 وقتها بدا جرس
المنفرد الموسيقي تيك بوم في ورشه مسرح
نيويورك مع اصحابه
في المسرحيه بيوصف الدوشه اللي في دماغه
وايه اللي اتعرض له ومن هنا بتبدا سرد
القصه بس دي ما كانتش البدايه البدايه
كانت سنه 1990 وقبل نجاح تكتك بوم وراند
كان في فشل زريعه واحباطات اكتر وخسر ناس
كتير والحكايه بدات في مطعم مون دانس
داينر ده المكان اللي كان شغال فيه في نفس
الوقت كان شغال على ورشه عمل لمشروع
الموسيقى العاطفي
وفي البدايه هنشوف قد ايه هو مضغوط نفسيا
وعايز ينجح باي شكل قبل ما يعدي 30 سنه
ولو مش عارف خليني اقول لك النظره دي جايه
منين اغلب مخرجي المسرح بيصنعوا قصص
نجاحهم قبل التلاتين على عكس مثلا اخراج
الافلام اغلب المخرجين بيظهروا فيه بعد سن
الخمسين برجوعنا لقصه جاناث هنشوفه وهو
بيصارع في كل لحظه بيصارع علشان شغله
الاساسي اللي هيسيبه بعد نجاح المسرحيه
وبيسرع مع حبيبته سوزان اللي بيجي لها عرض
شغل بره المدينه ومع صاحبه اللي بيحاول
يقنعه ويستغل مهاراته في الكتابه علشان
يزود دخله وسط كل الصراعات دي هو كل هدفه
انه ينجح المسرحيه وبينام وبيصحى وهو ده
شغله الشاغل ولكن الحقيقه الامور مش بتمشي
زي ما هو عايز بالعكس الامور بتتعقد يعني
وظيفه التدريس في مدينه تانيه وصديق مايكل
اللي ساب المسرح واشتغل في الاعلانات شايف
ان ده حاجه كويسه جدا ان يروح مع سوزن
ويبدا بدايه جديده ولكن كل ده ما كانش
مناسب لجن وكان رافضه بالكامل وفوق كل ده
بيطلب منه منتج المسرحيه انه يكتب اغنيه
جديده لان القصه محتاجه ده وهنا بيشوف
جانا سينو وهو بيحكي عن مثله الاعلى ستيفن
سوندي الا لما عرض عليه القصه قبل كم سنه
قال له ان القصه جميله جدا الاداء رائع
لكن شايف ان القصه ناقصها اغنيه في الفصل
الثاني جون بيفتكر ده وبيحس بغضب شديد جدا
وكل اللي بيسمعه صوت
لسه على المسرحيه اسبوعين جونسون مش قادر
يركز خصوصا محبطه منه بيبدا يفكر في عرض
مايكل مخاوفن بتزيد لما يعرف ان صديقك
كارولين ان فريدي المصاب بفيروس نقص
المناعه البشريه اتنقل للمستشفى وفي
النهايه بتتعب من هوسه بالشغل وبتقرر
تنفصل عنه
بيحبط جدا وبيضطر ان هو يحضر ورشه كتابه
علشان يجيب فلوس تغطي تكاليف المسرحيه في
الوقت ده بيحاول صديقه مايكل يشاركه ظروف
مرضه لكن بيكون مشغول جدا فمش بيسمعه
مايكل بيكون حاسس بغضب من ناحيه صديقه
لانه شايف انه بيتخلى عنه وبيتخلى عن كل
حاجه في مقابل المسرحيه مش مضمون هتنجح
ولا لا فضل الظروف دي وبعد ما وكيله
اعماله وروزه دايما بتتجنبه جاله مكالمه
من روزه بتطمنه وده بيشجعه ويكتب الاغنيه
الجديده في الليله السابقه وبالفعل بينجح
يكتبها رغم كل الضغط اللي كان حاسس بيه
وجه اليوم المنتظر وعملوا الورشه خلاص
تسقيف كتير تهاني كتير وحاجات كتير كويسه
لكن للاسف ما جاش ولا عرض انتاج للمسرحيه
وهنا كانت نقطه التحول بيتكلم وكيل اعمال
وروزه وبيقول لها
[موسيقى]
شغل في الاعلانات لكن مايكل بعد ما كان
بيشجعه على ده في الاول غير رايه بعد ما
شاف الورشه الخاصه بالمسرحيه مشجع جونثون
انه يكمل في المسرحيه لانه فعلا موهوب مش
معنى ان المسرحيه ما جاش ليها ولا منتج
فده مش معناه ان هو فاشل وفي نفس الوقت
شاركوا مايكل عن تعبه وفي اللحظه دي بيدري
ان هاوسو بالمسرحيه كلفه كتير خسر سوزان
واثر مع صديق ومايكل في النهايه بيحسن
علاقته مع مايكل وفي يوم عيد ميلاد جون
اتصل به
واتكلم معاه ورفع معنويات وقال له في
المره القادمه حاول للكتابه عن شيء تعرفه
هنا جونسون بيدرك ان طول الوقت كان بيلحق
حلم هو مش منتمي ليه وده اللي دفعه بعدها
لكتابه تيك تيك بوم ومن بعدها
اشتغل على
اشهر مسرح امريكي وكل المسرحيات الناجحه
طلعت
لكن للاسف في الليله اللي قبل عرض
المسرحيه بيتوفى لكن المسرحيه بتتعرض في
اليوم المحدد وبتنجح بشكل كاسح لدرجه انها
فضلت تتعرض في برودوي لمده 12 سنه بعد
وفاه جونسون وغيرت مفهوم المسرحيات
الموسيقيه في امريكا وقتها عن فيلم بيقول
النقد الفني
ميراندا وكاتب السيناريوس
استطاع ان يلتقط ذلك السحر في قصه لارسن
وان يصنع منه فيلما استثنائيا وبالكلام عن
المخرج فخليني اقول لك ان دي كانت التجربه
الاولى لميراندا كمخرج لان ميراندا اشتهر
بصناعته وتلحيمه لكتير من الموسيقى
الافلام واشهرهم
لكن المره دي قرر ان هو يخرج عن الطبيعي
وابهر الكل بالتجربه المميزه اللي قدموا
مع جارفيل الفيلم ابطال وقدوا اد جدا وحتى
لما النقاد اختلفوا فيه فالكل اشد به وقد
ايه هيسحرك بتفاصيله لحد اما توصل للاخر
وتبقى حاسس انك مش فاهم حاجه صحيح الفيلم
ماصورش معناه جونسون بشكلها الحقيقي لكن
ده ما يمنعش ان اندرو جارد في قدم لنا
فيلم مميز بكل تفصيله شوف الفيلم دلوقتي
واستمتع بيه واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه مع
فيلم جديد من بودكاست من وراء الافلام
المقدمه للعربيه
[موسيقى]